Hey
hello you ready to go okay
hustle big surprise I gotta go fast here
she comes
I'm filming me cuz cuz you're very cute
say hi say hi okay give
we're ready to go get settled so how was
your day yeah mm-hmm
what else just some fun surprises no I
tell you so okay so let me see I can see
you again this weekend is there one yet
no I thought you would remember
and when you when you feel sad I feel
sad and when you get stressed and so you
freaking did something a little crazy
the celebrate
I love hold my hand
to celebrate our life
that for this weekend we would come to
the city left left and so for the
weekend
we got off
the Paris France no Mike and we're on
the way to the arc for it right now
oh no way
go up and put liquor I took your car
home at such at my office
how'd you have
Alex [ __ ] the day off for Monday at your
work
so leaving tonight if we get the hard
time
how'd you get here
it's been a long day
but fine
are we going
no way No
really good time 7:30
oh my god
happy anniversary
can you tend this